e aí
um passarinho de toda cor gente de toda
cor amarelo rosa e azul me aceita como
eu sou eu hoje vim falar sobre aceitação
sobre inclusão mas o tempo todo vai
aparecer que eu estou falando de música
desde o ventre a música faz parte do meu
mundo eu presenciei minha mãe ensaiando
concertos para piano piano e canto piano
violino preparando recitais foi pelas
mãos dela que o iniciei e prosseguir com
os meus estudos de canto e piano a
música erudita era o que terminavam o
ambiente em que eu vivia e a música ela
ocupava as mais diversas situações fosse
celebrando com os amigos fosse dando
graças pelos alimentos entre nós irmãos
nós estávamos e tocavam juntos
assistindo a concertos aprendendo a
apreciar aprendendo a ouvir cada um de
nós tinha uma música letra e música
feita especialmente para cada um cada um
de nós tinha um chamado
eu decidi desde cedo que continuaria
levando música para o mundo foi aí que
eu comecei a ouvir música não dá
dinheiro música e o da minha fantasia
dizer assim então quem não faz música
deve ser milionário e a escassez de
milionários no mundo me chamou atenção
bem como escassez de música dentro das
casas essas constatações e fizeram ir
adiante com o meu projeto e eu fiz isso
através do meu canto dando concertos
cantando ópera fazendo música de câmera
e sempre me emocionou muito estar no
palco mas depois de um tempo o que
começou a chamar minha atenção era
plateia
e eu senti a falta de crianças me
assistindo eu não sabia se elas eram
excluídas por conta de serem muito
falantes e alegres para uma sala de
concerto ou se simplesmente eram
esquecidas
oi para o seu destrambelhado fraley da
com amor
e são tantas cores estão canto e sabores
eita me aceita como eu sou incluir a
criança na sala de concerto tornou-se a
minha música isso fez toda a diferença
para o que eu sou e faço hoje como tudo
é música harmonia do universo me trouxe
a laura de presente um bebê de 8 meses
filha de uma amiga a beatriz ela foi até
minha casa e disse que queria que a
filha tivesse a mesma formação musical
que eu tive e eu aceitei o desafio mas
disse que não sabia muito bem o que
fazer com ela mas que pediria ajuda a
minha mãe e assim foi feito enquanto
minha mãe me ensinava a ensinar a laura
eu ia percorrendo compreendendo todo o
caminho musical que ela percorreu comigo
e aí ensinar era reaprender a aprender
isso já era maravilhoso de viver quando
quatro meses após o nosso processo a
laura trouxer grande pérola de presente
ao final de uma consulta médica com sua
mãe a mulher preparava para ir embora
quando viu a grande surpresa ela diz
laura vamos a laura emendando cantando
uma cantiga que nós cantávamos da sala
de aula ela disse vamos dar a despedida
como faz o sabiá vai saindo vai dizendo
até logo até o fim a um médico
maravilhado que tem o que é isso essa
criança canta a mãe paquetá desse meu
deus ela tá falando a laura e trouxe a
confirmação de que esse seria o caminho
que o seguiria com a minha música e eu
começava a vislumbrar ali a música que
eu aprendi sobre o ponto de vista
pedagógico
e eu percebi que os bebês tinha
capacidade de ver e imitar isso é 33
anos atrás de ver imitar eu percebi a
capacidade de listinha está os sons os
sila as sílabas os gestos habilidade de
associar o gestos respectivos as canções
entende que elas compreendiam a melodia
das palavras e não significado
e era impressionante pensar que criança
falar inglês na inglaterra com um ano de
idade na alemanha gente o alemão
ah e assim por diante e se você tirar
uma criança de um país e levar para o
outro ela é capaz de aprender o idioma
em pouquíssimo tempo alice desenhava
toda a escola que chegaria até os dias
de hoje eu já sabia o que vinha viver
nesse mundo tava recebendo o desafio de
desenvolver os meus talentos as minhas
habilidades e era preciso aperfeiçoar os
caminhos que levariam crianças de
diferentes idades a responderem com a
rapidez da laura era preciso pensar em
recursos e jogos brincadeiras em rituais
em diálogos precisava criar uma
musicalização que permitisse uma maior
conexão da criança com ela mesma com o
crescimento dela com a nutrição dela com
os estímulos externos com a conexão dela
com outro e a conexão dela com o meio
eu era muito mais do que música
e o meu compromisso era com que essa
criança se tornaria no futuro com aquilo
que oferecia desenvolvi jogos
colaborativos que ressaltavam a beleza
ea força de cantarmos juntos cantar
junto é fundamental os jogos me traziam
essas possibilidade nós trabalhamos
sempre em roda e com bastão da fala na
mão isso trouxe organização e respeito a
escuta ea fala a escuta não só da música
mas a escuta do outro
a organizar o direito ao canto a voz que
canta é organizar o direito a voz que
fala
e isso é fundamental para o trabalho
para mim isso é o essencial você tem
direito a sala você sabe escutar você
sabe eu vi você tem o direito a sua fala
nesse caminho eu fui percorrendo várias
brincadeiras com as crianças ele
compreender de que forma poderia
melhorar isso tudo e cantar juntos é
como vamos estar juntos isso me remeteu
a imagem de uma mandala uma mandala de
conhecimentos de possibilidades de
trocas essa mandala ela tomou corpo e
prática na dinâmica das nossas aulas
então tudo que era pensado em forma de
conhecimento era feito numa mandala que
ela ela é colocada no centro da sala
dando uma noção de tribo e ela faz com
que a gente olhe na mesma direção todos
nós e a proporção que esse conhecimento
vai ser
e durante a aula a mãe dela vai se
desfazendo e alcides fazer isso vai
estar sendo conceito de eterna mudança
do aprendizado então estava tudo em seu
lugar a mãe dela continuava acontecendo
girando o aprendizado estava na hora de
sair do lugar e desafiar a música com
algo ainda maior
e foi então que chegou um menino chamado
victor um deficiente visual
e o pai dele me procurou
bom e queria colocar no para estudar
conosco mas ficou desanimado porque ele
achava que a certeza que seria
impossível adaptá-lo diante de tantos
estímulos visuais ali chegava alguém me
trazendo a oportunidade oportunidade de
fazer diferente e melhor tudo que eu
tinha feito até então a chegada do
victor fez festa no meu desejo de
inclusão da música
e eu precisava não pensar em nada
simplesmente resolvi não planejar nada
olá eu sou sim
o quê
[Música]
se você é a rosa certa bonita esperta
bom então eu segure na mão do victor e
seguir conseguir meu coração primeiro
dia de aula que eu apresentei o victor a
turma e não disse que era deficiente
visual não falei nada simplesmente
apresentei percebi que tinha que alinhar
o meu discurso pois era todo baseado na
visão eu dizia vocês viram que música é
linda olha esse som e assim por diante
era preciso rearrumar a forma de falar
quando eu tinha que pegar um instrumento
é para utilizar com ele eu ia até a
cestinha e voltava com ele para o centro
e retornar eu fui fazendo esse movimento
eu fui percebendo que quando meu
discurso foi ficando alinhado né o da
visão a visão trapaceada todos os outros
sentidos inclusive o da própria audição
da própria escuta foi look sensacional
descobriu isso porque assim o toque a
escuta
e são do espaço tudo ganhou outra
dimensão na nossa escola então isso de
levar o bico do pai até o caminho fazer
o caminho com ele pegar os instrumentos
de voltar para rodinha o que me marcou
profundamente foi inclusão natural das
crianças que na semana semana seguinte
né umas aulas seguinte sempre tinha uma
criança repetindo o meu gesto pegava o
victor ta na mão levava até a cestinha e
voltava com ele para roda ele foi
trazendo novos canais de conexão do
nosso trabalho para as nossas crianças
ele foi abrindo espaço para muitas
coisas diferentes na minha vida e na
vida das crianças é esse caminho
percorrido com ele até então precisava
ser aprimorado eu precisava criar novos
jogos reinventar os jogos passamos um
ano e sete meses pensando como
poderíamos fazer isso e trabalhando sem
e esse jogos ganharam volume e textura
e eles estão lindos eles chegaram para
escola para gente conseguir complementar
o trabalho que era feito com as outras
crianças quando eu apresentei o primeiro
jogo as crianças o victor ficou
encantado porque tudo que a gente falava
sobre as figurinhas e personagens
musicais ele conseguia ler com os dedos
para surpresa de todas as crianças como
é que ele conseguiu fazer aquilo ver com
as mãos se foi a primeira vez que eu
falei sobre a visão do victor
e eu tive dois presentes neste momento o
primeiro foi alegria dele em conhecer e
perceber os personagens que a gente
utilizava dentro de sala os nomes dele o
segundo presente foi que eu vi crianças
perto essa boca aberta disseram assim
mas ele já era cego na semana passada
é mas ele pega quanto tempo ele era cego
no espetáculo que a gente fez eles não
tinham essa percepção
e eles não tinham essa percepção eu vi a
beleza de cuidar das conexões o que
estava acontecendo agora era para o
mundo não era exclusivamente para o
victor cuidar do homem do futuro tomou a
intenção da nossa escola era precisa
fazer com que a criança se escutasse ela
já sabe escutar o outro e ser escutada
era preciso que ela se escutasse escutar
assim mesmo os seus desejos as suas
potências o seu lugar no mundo
e eu faço três perguntas na escola que
nortearam a minha vida e deram um
sentido para ela estão baseadas no alto
chamado deepak chopra que educou seus
filhos assim também fazendo essas três
perguntas e quanto mais eu me perguntava
e responde essas perguntas mas eu ia
tendo certeza da minha missão no mundo
que é e continuará sendo oferecer música
no estágio elevado de inclusão e de
conexão amorosa eu queria compartilhar
essas três perguntas com vocês vai se
responder internamente se quiserem
fechar os olhos fiquem à vontade
e aí
e o que será que eu vim fazer aqui nesse
mundo
e aí
[Música]
e quais são os meus dois
e quais são os meus talentos
e aí
[Música]
é com esses dois com esses talentos como
é que eu faço para ajudar quem está ao
meu lado humanidade inteira
e pode acreditar louca isso nem é tão
ruim mas por favor meu bem pode me
aceitar assim passarinho de toda cor
gente de toda cor amarelo rosa e azul me
aceita como eu sou passarinho de toda
gente de toda amarelo rosa e azul
é obrigada a minha versão muito obrigada
e aí